en fait le Sénat donc approuvé le texte
dans la nuit de samedi à dimanche le
gouvernement peut vous dire merci
non c'est le parlementarisme et le Louis
camerisme qui sortent grandit de
j'allais dire de ce vote sur le fond et
sur la forme vous êtes satisfait de la
manière dont cette réforme est passée au
Sénat
satisfait oui parce que on a fait notre
métier on a accompli notre mission
c'est-à-dire on a fait ce que doit faire
un parlement une assemblée parlementaire
on a été au bout du texte maintenant ça
paraît surprenant d'aller au bout d'un
texte mais je ne suis pas satisfait des
conditions dans lesquelles ça s'est fait
la question pourquoi parce que on est
passé d'une d'une gauche
sénatoriale qui était républicaine qui
était dans le dialogue qui est donné à
un caractère singulier à ce qui se
passait au Sénat à une gauche qui est
devenu la version le prolongement de la
nupesse au Sénat d'ailleurs
disait le Sénat ça doit pas être ni une
barricade ni un miroir je crois que la
volonté de la gauche sénatoriale c'était
de devenir une barricade d'empêcher
d'empêcher ils l'ont dit clairement le
vote de ce texte c'est une
de la façon de travailler au Sénat
[Musique]